j'ai eu honte j'ai jamais vu ça nulle
part si monsieur on voit sans louvre
petit corps je vous ai vu et vous m'avez
permis de vous embrassons pour envoyer
ça
je tends torche humains comme tu dis je
ferai ça pour quand le succès le comité
dans la rue à soma mais c'est de marcher
et au lieu des meilleurs la guerre nous
avait débarrassé de tous les imbéciles
heureusement qu'il reste quelques uns
parce que sinon toi et ta bourgeoise
vous dit marine tout seul
tu ramènes tout à toi il n'ya que toi
qui doute moi aussi je change un mot une
vie recule finaly pluméliau tu les juges
l'ontt avira ans aujourd'hui tous ces
bourgeois que je détestais sont devenus
des amis
raté un minable
tu vois quand vous savez entre chose
dans ce livre que tu étais daltoner de
plus ou moins inspirés de ta vie de
merde
tueur voleur et 1000 hommes avouent
ailleurs est un violeur un meilleure
chose qui me soit arrivée dans la vie si
2,8 me quitter c'est un battant
les tarifs d'être jalouse de ses oiseaux
bien ces modèles est pas là moi c'est la
peinture
je voudrais peindre comme tu écris s'en
passer des choses
d'entendre vaincre
comment tu t'appelles déjà mon tableau
planète il vous êtes artiste aussi c'est
un poète et un bon un très bon
luca violence aujourd'hui tout six
bourgeois que tu détestais sont devenus
des amis
tu as peut-être du génie ça reste encore
à prouver l'artiste a pas détruire eux
je voudrais peindre comme tu écris